this is an interesting vignette because
it's kind of shocking to us but of
course probably just some students
playing with designs but the fellow said
he walked into a room one day and
there's a scale model of the whole of
Cambridge and it's very plain that all
the all the pieces of wood that were red
were owned by Harvard and the ones that
were blue alone by MIT and he says bill
there's as dotted line running down the
middle of prospect street and river
street read on one side and blue on the
other and so it's like they're planning
to divide the whole city up but it's
probably some design school students
project but still it's the kind of thing
that people always think you know that
people are always accused of being
paranoid about the power of these
institutions but you know there's hardly
I could probably count on one fingers of
one hand the number of businesses in
central square that are still here that
were there when I came and all the
factories and businesses that were here
they're all gone and Harvard and MIT I
still here and still growing and no
matter who runs them or who comes and
goes the institution's live on you know
like the Commonwealth lives on we passes
shadows bad old joke i used to use but i
would stuff and say that if it weren't
for harvard and MIT cambridge would just
be another older urban northeastern city
on a river it's clear that MIT and how
its presence have just enormous impacts
on on the city positive impacts there
are very few negative do they their
demands on the housing market by some of
the graduate students yes but that's
going to happen in any college town if
you're going to be a college town to
deal with that issue let the college's
be have it at MIT Cambridge is Cambridge
in good part because of institutions
like MIT entirety
and a hundred years of MIT I think
obviously look at Kendall Square I mean
Kendall Square has grown because of the
MIT connection and influence I mean is
grown in a big way it's provided jobs
it's provided great financial resources
to the community it's provided quality
construction it's now addressing you
know issues that are at the heart of a
lot of neighborhood concerns so I think
you know it's provided educational
opportunities for people all around the
world as well as many Cambridge
residence it's a center of research to
center of ideas so you know MIT
Cambridge wouldn't be Cambridge you know
without an MIT and that you know that
that's I'm not saying that in any way
other than to say I think that's the
truth that we are lucky as a community
to have MIT I think MIT is lucky as an
institution to be situated in a city
like Cambridge that thinks about you
know the management of its city and the
welfare of its residents in a way that
will challenge the university